hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the setup tour project 2014.
so i realized i really like watching
setup tours like they're a great way to
get to know
a better way to do your work or how
someone's workflow works or how they
operate or what tools they use to get
the work done that they do and that's
why i watched a lot of setup tour
projects and as a matter of fact that
was actually the inspiration for the
last setup tour project that i did if
you're new here which you probably are
then you may have missed it or not seen
it yet so i'll have that as the first
link right below that like button but
essentially when i first moved into this
new place
i had the setup tour project and took a
ton of ideas from the setup tours that
you guys submitted and incorporated them
into my own uh and that's changed a lot
of the way i work so that's pretty cool
but this is a setup to our project and
the concept here is pretty simple it's
the largest tech collab on youtube i'd
like to think uh and the idea is you
submit a setup tour of your workspace or
it could be your mom's or your brothers
or your friends or whoever's but submit
a mini tour of that workspace the key
here with the video that you make is
brevity so you'll make a 15 to 30 second
video for the tour and you can use
anything from your phone to your dslr it
doesn't actually matter but obviously
the higher quality the better you know
me i like pixels now the key is if you
can try to get two main things in the
video if you submit one one try to get a
wide angle shot of everything so that it
would include like the entire desk or
the entire workspace and then two pick
something to highlight pick something
really unique whether it's your monitors
or your desk or something custom made or
your cable management setup whatever it
happens to be laptop desktop anything
and really highlight that in the video
because that's what's going to be giving
people ideas of things they may not have
already seen yet or never even done you
don't have to talk in the video it's not
really totally necessary but it usually
does help if you do now once the video
is made you should submit this by
emailing the video file to
setuptorproject
gmail.com i will be receiving all the
video files and there is actually a file
size limit to you'll notice gmail you
can't really send anything over 20 or 25
megabytes so you can use a service like
dropbox or google drive if your file is
big enough that you need to do that also
when you send it be sure to include a
link or a title uh for me to give a
shout out to whatever your youtube
channel your twitter because there will
be shout outs so you have about two
weeks to submit a video if you choose to
do so so on valentine's day february
14th it'll close and the end result of
this project will be a compilation video
of the best high quality short setup
tour videos that are submitted uh so get
your submission if you want and also
share this video because well if you
want to see awesome setup tours you got
to share it and get it to people who
have awesome setups or who just like
watching high quality setup tours share
it with your favorite youtuber who might
have an awesome setup and maybe they'll
submit one at the end of all this of
course i'll be watching everything
that's submitted and i'll probably take
a lot of your ideas into account and
i'll be uploading my own setup tour
likely as a separate video but uh
that'll be the conclusion that'll be it
so get your video in if you want tag
someone below if you want them to make a
setup tour
and that's about it so thanks for
watching i also have a couple of reviews
in the works as well so if you want to
stay tuned to see those be sure to
subscribe below if you haven't already
again thank you for watching and i'll
talk to you guys in the next one peace
[Music]
you